well vice president vice president
kamala harris is the first woman to hold
national office
her list of firsts doesn't end there she
went to howard university she was a
member of a black sorority there
and they are key aspects that shaped her
life bianca holmen has reaction from
local alumni
and sorority sisters i
kamala davey harris to solemnly swear
i kamala davey harrison as the first
black and south asian woman to be vice
president
kamala harris is a symbol of possibility
she's always proudly displayed her love
for her sorority
and alma mater atar hasiboula is a
howard alum and new executive director
of the local aclu
many of us view her as our howard sister
and
she's been an inspiration to a lot of
folks harris graduated from the
historically black university in 1986
with a degree in political science
and economics this is an affirmation
that if you attend an hbcu and you're a
graduate of an hbcu
the world is really your oyster harris
is also a member of alpha kappa alpha
the country's first black sorority
founded at howard black sororities and
fraternities
play a role in ensuring social justice
for the black community
it's about service to all mankind so
since 1908
that's what we've been doing is giving
back to the community
local chapter president bernar rhodes
ford says this is an incredible moment
for members
it's overwhelming and brings one uh
specifically me to the point of tears
harris is the first woman to hold this
office
but both hacibula and rose ford agree
she will not be the last
the future generations certainly look
brighter than what the past has afforded
us
the glass ceiling it is shattered we
know
little girls know that they can do
anything they want to do they can be
anything they want to be
diversity modeled by the president and
vice president is represented
throughout the white house reporting
bianca holman
8 news now and on that note half of
president biden's cabinet nominees are
people of color
if approved it would be the most diverse
administration in u.s history